[Music]
but she was
more like a beauty queen from a movie
[Music]
is
[Music]
dance
[Music]
my mother
[Music]
she
she says
[Music]
[Music]
just remember to always say twice
do a dance
[Music]
oh
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
she
[Music]
oh
[Music]
like
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
us
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
me
be
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
saturday
[Laughter]
saturday
oh
[Music]
[Music]
every night in my dreams
i see you i feel you
that is how i know
you go
far across the distance
spaces between us
you have come to show
[Music]
the heart
[Music]
the
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the 45th president of the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
cause there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
[Music]
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where it is
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
[Applause]
[Music]
land
[Music]
who died who gave
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Applause]
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the heroes of tennessee
well we won pennsylvania last time and
we're going to win it by a lot more this
time i can see
[Applause]
because you know four years ago we had a
lot of enthusiasm but we have more now
even the fake news will admit that they
will
there's more than we've ever had hello
pennsylvania thank you very much for
being here
we stand together in the rain it's
supposed to bring luck we'll take it oh
my man
i just came from the rose garden of the
white house
[Music]
thank you very much and i love you too
[Applause]
or i wouldn't have done this i wouldn't
have done it but we're doing well
our country is going to be
stronger than ever before very soon you
watch it's happening it's all happening
beautifully it's happening we had to
close it down
we saved millions of lives we opened it
up and we're doing record
kind of numbers and we're gonna have the
best year we're gonna have a great third
quarter
so thank you very much
[Applause]
i've just come from the rose garden of
the white house
where i proudly nominated judge amy
coney barrett to the united states
supreme court
judge barrett is a brilliant legal mind
an extraordinary scholar you know
that number one in her class you know
the uh
the professor one of the most respected
people he said the greatest
student he's ever had that's pretty good
that's a little better than biden
wouldn't you say she should be running
for president
now it's a little bit better
academically slightly better
and most important of all she will
defend your god-given rights and
freedoms she will
judge barrett would become the third
supreme court justice
along with over 300 think of this
this is our third nomination we have
justice gorsuch justice kavanaugh
and now we have amy along with over 300
federal judges by the end of this term
and we've confirmed to uphold our laws
and constitution
as written and that's a record joe biden
has refused to provide his list because
the names will be hand-picked
by socialists like representatives
alexandria ocasio-cortez
aoc plus three and either hand omar
that's a great one she's a great we're
always complaining she's always
complaining came here
things worked out for her how did she
come here does anybody know how she came
here
aoc plus three that's a beauty that's a
group of
real they love our country so much
if given power the far left will pack
the supreme court with radicals who will
terminate
the second amendment that's what they
want to do strike the words under god
from your pledge of allegiance tear down
crosses from public spaces and force
taxpayers
to fund extreme late term abortion
that's what they're looking to do
these left-wing justices will [ __ ]
police departments
protect sanctuary cities and declare the
death penalty unconstitutional
for even the most depraved mass
murderers it's unconstitutional
we will save your second amendment and
together we will save
our country and that's what we're doing
[Applause]
that's a lot of people
so we have tens of thousands of people
if sleepy joe came here
if he had i really mean this you know
the little circles he felt
they can't get them full you have like
five of them
there's circles those big beautifuls
whoever does it does a nice job they're
very round
but he's got like five of them and then
he stands very far
back and walks and i mean i don't get
the whole deal there i don't get it
so we have tens of thousands somebody
said 17 18
000. last night we had 35 000 people you
saw that in virginia
you know we're making a play for
virginia
because we have a governor in virginia
you know that he wants to totally end
all he does is talk about
terminating the second amendment that's
all he talks about
that's all he talks about in 38 days we
will win the commonwealth of
pennsylvania we will win
four more years in the white house
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you very much great honor it's a
great honor we've achieved a lot
together it's together
it's what happened well you see the
numbers on november 3rd get out and vote
go early vote do whatever you have to do
make sure they don't cheat you too badly
with those ballots oh did you see today
there was a big mishap with the ballots
another one
this is every day they have that mic
every day big mishap with the uh ballots
so uh one of them new york is saying
well we're going to change the system a
little bit
it's a little late for doing that is
new york wants to change their system
they're going to work on something
governor cuomo he's going to work on
something now
well the ballots are flowing you know
it's a little late
and then in a certain location you know
the location
they mailed a thousand ballots out
they doubled it up and everybody in this
democrat area got two ballots instead of
one and then two days ago
they found eight ballots in a waste
paper basket unfortunately
they all had the name trump written on
them we were going to vote for trump
they were military ballots the military
and then they have a stream in a very
good state and they found
lots of ballots dumped in the stream
look
look you know this is not right what
they're doing
is not right and it's all run by these
ballots the ones we're talking about
whether it's pennsylvania because we're
going to win in pennsylvania you got to
watch but you have a governor
who's in charge of ballots
north carolina michigan
nevada all of these places they're all
run by democrats they're the ones that
count the ballots
and there's no does anybody have even a
doubt it's just like common sense it's
common sense
so we're going to be very careful we're
going to watch and you know we're
waiting for rulings from
a great federal judge in your state
federal judge
about the constitutionality of the whole
thing they're going to try and steal the
election
look at this crowd the only way they can
win pennsylvania frankly
is to cheat on the ballots that's the
way i look at it
[Applause]
no they just had a big thing today they
said there was a mistake
made on a lot of the ballots they're
going to try and redo the system
take a look at iowa during the primary
remember the first primary
they couldn't do anything it was all a
mess it was all a mess
good job good job look at this guy good
job
good job
hey good job
man
that guy he's going home to his parents
now he's going to be a big job
but but wait a minute wait wait
he just opened his mouth and we had that
gentleman in the beautiful blue will you
stand up
are you in love law enforcement just
because you were on him
this guy hadn't gotten the first word
out that's the kind of guy i want
working for me right there
man right that was just
instinct it's called natural instinct
some people have it and some people
don't
unfortunately most people don't that's
the problem
under my administration we proudly
achieved
energy independence we are now the
number one producer of oil and natural
gas
in the world
[Applause]
sleepy joe biden is vowed to ban
fracking that's not good for
pennsylvania
you notice now he's trying to pull back
you know he went to a place called texas
no oil no god and no guns in texas that
doesn't work
but you know what does it work here
either you're a big fracker
you uh it's a big business here 900 000
jobs
but uh he wants to eradicate all of the
things that you're doing
all of the things that are bringing in
so much money for your state it's a
disgrace
now he's trying to say well i didn't
really mean that that was like hillary
remember
she made a horrible statement about
clean coal
and then she went crooked hillary and
then she went
three weeks later
i agree
all right you know i used to say now now
now we won we won
now don't do it but they say locker but
i try and stop it now i
she's crazy
bill is stone cold afraid of her
no but how about remember the emails oh
you think we forgot we didn't forget
the emails remember the emails when
congress said we want 33 000 emails
and they deleted emails they deleted
everything
the text messages everything they
deleted
if mike kelly did that he'd be out of a
job so fast
he'd be gone right he'd be gone we were
nervous we wouldn't last long i mean the
corruption hey did you see though over
the last
48 hours the fbi tapes the fbi text
messages
trump was right the one guy says trump
was right he was right you shouldn't be
doing this trump was right he was
like the honest one but they brought him
along we need insurance we have to get
insurance for this
this is wrong what we're doing trump was
right
it turned out that it was a whole big
disinformation
deal and you know who the guilty party
is
the democrats and hillary they were the
ones
that dealt with russia it wasn't us
which we've been saying for a long time
no these text messages just came out
did you see that they just came out so
we went through two and a half years
of a lot of work and they ruined a lot
of people
look at general flynn look at what
happened those messages about general
flynn last night just came out
they know they knew he was innocent they
said
we want flynn in order to get trump we
want flynn they were after trump
it came out loud and clear they were
after trump i'll tell you what
uh we got to get back to congress and go
after these people these people are sick
there was a whole big con job with
shifty schiff and the whole group shift
the shift he gets up and says a totally
different thing than what i said
totally different and they say sir you
can't go after him because he's shielded
because he made the speech he totally
lied he made it in congress and he can
say anything see it should be the
opposite
when you're in congress you should be
more honest what a sleazebag he is right
he always
[Applause]
what a sleazebag he is what a jerk
not a jerk we gotta deal with people
like that
i'll tell you i tell you how do you come
together with people like that they're
totally dishonest because i want the
country to come together
you know we were coming together until
we got hit with a plague
from china we were coming together there
was i was getting calls from
stone cold radical left hard-line
democrats let's start talking i'm
telling you
because we had the best unemployment
numbers we ever had
the best economy best stock market
although the stock market right now is
just about there right
success will bring us together then we
got hit with the plague from
china and now we have to do it all over
again it's make america great again
again
[Applause]
but we saved millions of lives by doing
what we did when asked about fracking
sleepy joe biden said that he would make
sure it's eliminated this was just a
little while ago
then he gets the nomination he goes well
i didn't think fracking's that bad it's
amazing isn't it
that's what you call a really dishonest
dumb politician a dumb guy
always known as a dumb guy but we look
forward to seeing him in the debate he's
got a lot more experience he's got 47
years i've got three and a half years
so we'll see he's got 47 years of
experience
you know i always sort of smile when he
said like criticism
we should have done this we should have
done that we should all these things
right
i said why didn't you do him he's been
there for and it's not like he left
20 years ago 47 years and he left three
and a half years ago right
so why the hell didn't you do him now he
went just all these great ideas that's a
real beauty
days ago biden reiterated his pledge to
require
net zero carbon emissions which he
doesn't have any idea what that means
shutting down all fracking and sending
you jobs overseas like they've been
doing i'm bringing your jobs back
they're all coming back
and i'll keep you jobs in pennsylvania
where they belong that's where they
belong what they've done to you
and other states joe biden's agenda
would also be a nightmare for
pennsylvania seniors do we have any
seniors here don't raise your hand
do we have any seniors not to look how
few people raise their hands i can see
some sages
we're proud of it right for years biden
tried to cut social security and
medicare you know that
he wants to go you know what's going to
happen they're going to go with
socialized medicine if they ever got in
remember obama what he said and by the
way obama knew all about the scam he
knew all about this coup he knew all
about spying on my campaign
he knew everything
[Music]
somebody said well we can't go you know
they haven't called
they have them called
remember i said there was spying on my
campaign a long time ago the internet
blew up
how dare he say that how did it turn out
to be true
and then it was the coup because i got
in now they said all right he got in
we couldn't stop him now we're going to
try taking it away can you believe it
this is
the u.s say no seriously can you believe
it and we caught up
all these text messages and from what i
hear they have some real beauties coming
out over the next couple of days so stay
tuned
[Music]
but somebody said oh you can't do that
he was president well i'm president too
and they would not stop i promise
these people are sick they're bad people
remember when biden said when i
argued that we should freeze federal
spending
i meant social security he meant this he
said
when i argued that he wanted to freeze
all spent
all this federal spending he wanted he's
not going to take care of your medicare
he's not going to take care of your
social security
and if he gets in he's going to have
nothing to say because
the radical left will control it and
he's going to do socialized medicine
as sure as you're sitting or standing
there i don't i can't even tell the hell
difference
you're sitting they're nice we got seats
for people
who do who would do this look at all the
police back there what
are they degraded
[Music]
right now
they're great people we got so many
endorsements i don't even talk about
them anymore we have so many police
endorsements new york city's finest
never did it before they endorse
they endorse me they endorse
for us they could solve that problem in
new york all they'd have to do is let
them do their job
and don't take a billion dollars away
and fire some of the best people
on the force which is what they did we
got chicago
think of that chicago police endorse me
how about that that's not easy to do
you're dealing with radical left people
we got endorsed by all the sheriffs in
florida all law enforcement in florida
we got endorsed by texas oklahoma
we got endorsed by does anybody know of
any police
area or group that is not endorsed
we're looking for him
now biden is pledging to give federal
health care
to illegal aliens which is
decimating medicare
just so you understand we all have heart
we want to help people but the problem
is when you say that
people that never even thought of coming
to the united states
say let's go where are we going we get
free education
we get free medicare free health care
and then i jokingly said one time
everybody gets a beautiful brand new
rolls royce and cnn said
he lied he said then all illegal
immigrants
got a 750 000
they said he lied i didn't i was only
kidding
they said they said i lied over the road
so i say y'all said to you remember when
i said
russia if you're listening find her
emails or whatever the hell i say
find her emails and then we all left
together 25 000 people in the stadium
on television look at all the cameras on
television look at those people
look at all those red lights they're
going on they're standing in the rain
just like i am but they don't like it
but do you remember but the problem is
they cut it off exactly before we all
started to laugh together right
after two years they've been saying he
dealt with russia
he asked russia to please get her emails
or whatever the hell we were asking for
russia if you're listening please get
the whole place cracks up along with me
in fact they cut off my last word you
know they got to cut it sharp
because they don't want to see any sign
this is how dishonesty is they are
really i'll tell you they are so bad for
the country
but i'll take it back for right now
because right now it's live all over the
place
we'll let it go you know what let's say
it at the end instead
because so often i'll say you know this
cnn they're totally corrupt they're fake
and
you see the light go off the red like
and i said i gotta stop saying that
do you think it's wet enough out here
they all said sir would you need a hat i
said what the hell hat
is going to match this beautiful type
that i've just
i got a red one i don't know red and
whatever the hell color this is
red is not going to go well with this
color
no it's fine i like seeing the rain with
my friends from pennsylvania i don't
care
[Applause]
you're in the rain together right
in the rain together
thank you thank you very much
now we're in the rain together we'll
stay out here all night if we have to
but i'll tell you uh so many interesting
things are going on when i look at
their plans did you see their plans the
manifesto
that's the bernie sanders and aoc
manifesto
so normally when you negotiate with
communists because i don't think it's
social haven't they gone over the
i don't think it's this is no longer
socialism we're dealing with worse and
so
this is communism but when you deal with
socialist government
you know you're supposed to bring them a
little bit to the right right you know
you're a democrat you bring
they brought they started with a plan
and they went further left
this plan is the most horrible we call
it the
bernie sanders crazy bernie but you know
the one thing they agree with us on
trade because we are being ripped off by
so many countries i've stopped a lot of
it
i mean i had to devote a lot of time to
a fake impeachment now you see how fake
the impeachment was
what about biden's son getting three and
a half million dollars
right from the wife of the mayor of
moscow and then they say donald trump is
dealing with
russia donald trump i never even made a
call
donald trump is dealing this guy got
three and a half
million dollars from the wife of the
mayor
of moscow what the hell was that for
probably his great experience in energy
but he didn't have that
and then it revealed yesterday that he
got a lot more money from china than we
thought
and he got a lot more money right it's
all stuff it's
it's like perfect it's like unbelievable
but he got a lot more money from china
and the 100
the 83 or 63 000 a month that he was
getting
now it looks like it was 183
000 a month and he got an upfront
payment of three million dollars from
ukraine
and this is because of his great
knowledge of energy but he had none
they said do you know anything about
energy no i don't happen to know
anything no
and then the father called for the
prosecutor get him out are you not
getting your billion dollars from the
united states
whoa they got him out and here's your
billion that's not a quid pro quo right
but a perfect phone call is a quid pro
quote where nothing was
it's a disgrace well hopefully we're
getting to the bottom of all that stuff
because we got plenty
the biden's plan for mass amnesty would
bankrupt your social security system
and you remember me when i got elected
they all said oh he's gonna hurt they
love to say that's gonna hurt because
they give disinformation
they say a lie like the soldiers and the
graves
and they put it in can you imagine no no
animal that i know would say that nobody
they make up a lie and then they go with
it social security they said four years
ago now they say it again
he will by the way your social security
we never touched it not even touched it
they said he will destroy your social
security no
they will destroy because they'll
destroy your country and your social
security will be worthless that's what's
going to happen
in just three and a half years we've
secured
america's borders rebuilt the awesome
power of the u.s military
obliterated 100 of the isis caliphate
[Applause]
[Music]
fixed our disastrous trade deals and
brought jobs
back home to america and back home
to the commonwealth of pennsylvania
under 16 years of presidents
obama and bush household income rose
only two thousand
nine hundred and forty five dollars
these are right out of the book
so 16 years less than three thousand
in three years with us it rose six
thousand four hundred and eighty three
so much less than half the time
and if you include energy savings how do
you like paying those two dollars for
gasoline and even less i feel like
and your electric bills lay down number
one in the world how do you like that if
you include that it's ten thousand
dollars that's over three years three
and a half years we lifted
6.6 million people out of poverty which
is a record
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world and now we are very
very rapidly it's you see the numbers
it's happening all over again
we've added a historic 10.6 million jobs
in the last four months
there's never been a record like that
we've added more jobs at any time four
months not even close
and to fight the china virus we launched
the largest national mobilization since
world war
ii you know they said how did i say we
get an
a-plus but i get a d in public relations
because we were so busy working and you
know when you give it to the fake news
they reported incorrectly so i figured
what's the use of even dealing with
we got we did a job including
ventilators that nobody had you know we
took over the cupboards were
bare while we took over we pioneered
life-saving therapies reducing the
fatality rate
85 since april
who ever heard of that
and europe which is having a big surge
right now you know they used to use
europe oh look how europe's still
uh we're doing well and we don't want
them to have a surge
europe has had almost a 50 percent
greater excess mortality
rate than the united states you don't
want to hear that they don't want to
tell you that
our early and aggressive actions save
millions of lives through operation warp
speed
we will develop and distribute a vaccine
in record time
we're going to have it very very soon
they're very upset with the vaccine
they're very upset with the vaccine
because it's happening too soon they
don't want it now
even though it's saving lives it's going
to save tremendous lives
they don't want to hear it they don't
want to hear about the therapies they
just want to get through the election i
heard
one state did you hear this we're going
to open up our schools on
november 6th oh i told you that right
everything's don't worry about it
pennsylvania your state's going to be
open like on november 4th
this was some idiot and now they're
excoriating this person that said it
they're excoriating the person that said
it we're going to open up our schools in
november 6th the latest november 9th oh
that's nice
got to open your schools you got to open
up your state open it up
the ones that are doing well are the
ones that opened it up
we will crush the virus our opponents
will crush america and that's what it's
about
to they will they will deliver a
crippling shutdown and a steep
you will have if sleepy joe biden
becomes president first of all you're
going to have a massive tax increase
you're going to see interest rates go
through the ceiling you will have a
depression
the likes of which this country has
never seen before and i'm including 1929
that was a pretty bad one all right
that's what's going to happen i hope i
don't get a chance to be tested
because i don't want to be tested i
don't want to have him and say see i was
right
because with us you're going to have
incredible prosperity we're cutting
taxes
and we're growing fast i'm delivering a
safe vaccine in
record time that's the other thing in uh
with the vaccine
because of me and the faa
they're approving things in a fraction
of the time you wouldn't have had a
vaccine
if you had to go through that obsolete
process
you wouldn't have had a vaccine for two
and a half more years on november 3rd
pennsylvania will decide
whether we end the pandemic defeat the
virus and return to record prosperity
or whether we allow sleepy joe biden to
kill the recovery
delay the vaccine impose a four trillion
dollar
tax hike
destroy your suburbs everyone's talking
about me in the suburbs
i'm not housing in the suburbs
and then i hear all the people in the
suburbs don't like me you better like me
because you're going to have
your suburbs aren't going to be so great
they say that
women in the suburbs i made the mistake
i said
housewives living in the suburbs they
said oh that's politically incorrect
okay i got kills for that he used the
word housewife is that an unacceptable
term i know
they're all saying no i said the
housewives in the suburbs and they said
oh what a horrible thing to say
but women let's be politically correct
women and men
in the suburbs they're changing the
zoning so they can build that's what it
is
they're changing your zoning it was a
rule a regulation that was a disaster
and i called my people i said i want to
terminate it they said sir we can't do
that let's uh just amend it we'll make
it
much no no you don't understand i don't
want to amend it i want to terminate it
yes sir and we terminated it
[Applause]
but if you believe the fake suburb polls
i don't think people in the suburbs know
that i did that i don't think they know
that i did it
you know they say we want sleepy joe
biden why why do you want him
first of all you're not getting him
you're getting this maniac
who was falling like a rock in the polls
he picked somebody that he should have
never picked she was so bad to him she
said such bad things about him
i'm not gonna pick somebody that says
bad and then on top of it
right 15 14 13
10 eight seven
then she went up back to eight she had a
big week and then she went back down
and she got out at one or two she quit
before iowa right
and then they had the iowa primaries and
because they used these crazy ballots
nobody ever found out who won
and now they want to use it on a scale
that's a thousand times bigger for our
80 million ballots
80 million ballots they couldn't count a
small number but now they count and then
they had the race in new york
carolyn maloney terrible terrible
congresswoman
and they took it away from the guy that
was meeting her or would have beat her
but they're missing massive you know
it's not like they're missing one
percent which would be unacceptable you
know one percent you can win by one
percent right
can win by one tenth of one percent but
then listen like there was one area i
think 41
of the 41.
these people are crazy this is going to
be a disaster
and all i'm asking is people go out to
vote go out to vote
and stop with this nonsense because
we're going to be counting ballots for
the next two years
and i don't want to end up in the
supreme court and i don't want to go
back to congress either even though we
have an advantage if we go back to
congress does everyone understand that
i think it's 26 to 22 or something
because it's counted
one vote per state so we actually have
an advantage oh they're going to be
thrilled to hear that
i'm sure they're trying to figure out
how can we break that one
biden wants to confiscate your guns and
indoctrinate your children
with poisonous anti-american lies in
schools right
to combat the toxic left-wing propaganda
in our schools i announced last week
that we are launching a new pro-american
lesson plan for students called
the 1776 commission
[Music]
right
we'll teach our children the truth about
america that we are the most exceptional
nation on the face of the earth and we
are only getting better we're getting
better let's say healing for us
this is the most important election
we've ever had i'm telling you
you know i used to say like even a
couple of months ago well you know
20 how do you how do you like 2016 that
was pretty
exciting right was that exciting was
that the coolest night
trump is winning florida he's winning
north carolina he's winning
pennsylvania's winning michigan is
winning wisconsin
he's winning everything what the hell is
going on and people crying they cried
the anchors the non-biased anchors are
crying oh
i watched an interview with a person on
msdnc i don't watch it much but i watch
because sleepy show was on
and she's like did you see that
interview yesterday it was like
and she's very tough very very tough
she's very nasty
and she's feeding them can't answer it
so what she's doing is
no no isn't it true yes isn't it true
that trump is a horrible human being
uh well uh uh yes i yeah as we discussed
before it's true is
this was the worst most obviou and this
was a killer this
this person is very tough it is so
rigged the whole thing is rigged
we got to beat the system and we're
beating the system
sometimes i'll look i'll look and i'll
have somebody in the office that's
a corrupt you know corrupt media person
and i'll be sitting there complaining
how unfair it is
and then i'll be sitting in the oval
office but i'll be saying how unfair it
is then i'll look around the oval office
i say wait a minute
it's unfair but oh we're in the oval
office and you're not okay
and i stopped complaining mike
they said oh this is the oval office
isn't it joe biden has surrendered his
party to the flag
rioters the anti-police radicals the
anarchists
[Music]
[Applause]
his running mate urged supporters to
donate to a fund that bailed out riders
out of jail including
an attempted cop killer let's get him
out of jail
13 members of biden staff donated to the
same fund they donated a lot of money
too we want to get these people out
uh we want to be called in you know you
saw what we did in minneapolis
when they called us like a week and a
half too late we went in how long did
that take about a half hour it was over
we brought in the national guard we told
seattle we're coming in and they left
that night
we're all set to go and we wanted i was
so disappointed
i was disappointed ah that we were going
to make a big statement but we couldn't
because they said
okay they left shouldn't have told them
next time don't tell them please
and you know and if you look at
portland what a mess right that's an
anarchist that's sort of like a
different chicago's a mess
new york what they've let happen to new
york and we have these great police in
chicago new york they can do the job
just let them do the job
it's terrible but but you look at
portland
portland is anarchist and you had the
guy two weeks ago i remember he shot and
killed the young man in the middle of
the street just shot him like
oh i don't even say like what because
his parents
are so devastated a young man and they
shot him and killed him this one guy
this one animal and two and a half
that's right over his hat
not our hat it was another hat it was a
christian hat it was a christian hat
he was a christian he was a christian
and they shot him
killed him instantly and this guy that
shot him everybody knew who he was
right and i said after two days where is
he did you arrest him no he didn't
after two and a half days did you arrest
him and then i put out on
social media why didn't you arrest him
and you know what the u.s marshal saw it
they went in and he pulled a gun on him
and 15 minutes it was all over none of
our guys were hurt
guy was a stone cold killer and yet they
say he was a uh
protester not a protester an anarchist
and a killer
and the u.s marshals thank you that was
an incredible job they did
brave
but the u.s marshals we could solve that
problem so easy we'd put them in there
so easy but they don't want the governor
doesn't want them
the governor wants to leave it that way
can you imagine what a messed up but
this but many
you know this is for years that's been
going on in portland
i said what do the streets look like
they said you wouldn't believe it people
put up
two by four still fronts they don't want
to buy new because they know somebody's
going to knock them down within two
weeks it's a terrible thing
the democrat party's war on cops is
putting our police officers
at risk as president i will always stand
with the heroes of law enforcement all
right
you see how much the people love you
they really do you know you don't hear
that
you don't hear that but the people love
and respect the job you do you know you
don't hear it because these
maniacs right back there they know what
they're right but
they do love you and and uh and respect
you so much so thank you very much
but that's why law enforcement
organization around the country
all organizations that's why they're
endorsing me and
strongly opposing my opponent and the
radical left and my opponent again is
is controlled like a puppet by these
people by these crazy people i'm proud
to have received the first ever
unanimous endorsement from the largest
police union in the world
the fraternal order of police
[Applause]
largest in the world
and we're joined tonight by their
president a fantastic
guy friend of mine pat yos
and several hundred of their brave
officers pat
come on up come on up
[Music]
mr president thank you you know across
the station there are some eight hundred
thousand police uh police officers put
on a uniform every day men and women who
go into communities
place their own safety at risk to
protect our communities across america
and it seems like overnight people have
turned their back
on america's law enforcement we went
from public servants to public enemies
overnight
because many politicians turn their back
on us you sir have never turned your
back
on america's law enforcement
well sir i am here to tell you that on
behalf of america's largest
law enforcement organization
rank-and-file police organization
we give you our our unanimous and
enthusiastic endorsement and we will not
turn our back on you
together we are going to make america
safe again
thank you
[Music]
wow wow
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
november 3rd get out there and vote and
keep your eyes open
if you see any shenanigans which you
probably will
okay if you see people like dumping
things flushing things if you see people
dropping them in a
in a waste paper basket seven or eight
right no waste paper keep your eyes open
this is a smart group of people right
here
also with us are a group of warriors
from washington that are
fantastic that love you and we'll start
dan
muser dan thank you very much
where's dan
that's not a very good location dan
that's not like
thank you dan congressman scott
perry scott
thank you great job these are warriors
i'm telling you
they fight they fight as hard as you can
fight
every one of them lloyd smucker
floyd thank you thank you lloyd
thank you thank you lord great job
congressman fred keller
[Music]
thank you great job
the great john joyce thanks john
and a real good friend of mine and
somebody that i'll tell you he's as
tough as they come and he loves
pennsylvania mike kelly
[Applause]
thank you man you like having these guys
by your side
also a man sort of a legend i would say
around here
he told me a long time ago four years
ago he told me you're gonna win
i said how do you know he said i know i
know i can tell he said i see people
with trump stuff on that never cared
about a politician
in their life now they get the hat and
the sash and the belt in the shoes
he said i've never seen he called it a
long time ago
former congressman we got to get him
back in i guess
well he left because he had a lot of
good things to do but he's fantastic oh
we got to get him back
lou barletta
great guy
and we have a congressional candidate
who i hear is leading
jim bognet where's jim jim i hear you
leaving
you'll get involved you have my total
endorsement okay you know that
total endorsement for jim my
pennsylvania campaign chair bernie
comfort bernie thank you
thank you thank you very much
great guy great what a great job huh
wow have you done it have you done a job
thank you how are we doing by the way
bernie
you have done it yet thank you very much
and also state gop chairman a friend of
mine for a long time
lawrence tavis lawrence
[Applause]
thank you that's a great group of people
thank you all we're gonna have a big
victory lawrence you agree with bernie
right
i think we're gonna have a big big
victory bigger than even four years ago
that was good
you know remember they wouldn't announce
it
we were like a point up one of which you
know some people says a lot i think
we'll do a lot better this time
because at that time i did i said i was
going to do things but you know it's
like
a lot of people say things now i've
accomplished more than i ever said i
would in the campaign
[Applause]
but uh i think we're going to have the
kind of numbers that people are going to
be very surprised at
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over his 47 years
in politics along with his other friends
he championed every globalist portrayal
of pennsylvania
for almost half a century he supported
nafta
got rid of that one south korea
renegotiated that one tpp got out of
that one
and china's entry into the world trade
organization
which he said was a wonderful thing no
it wasn't it was a terrible thing
that's when china took off like a rocket
ship but you know what
china was going to overtake us for 10
years they said 2019
2019 they're going to overtake guess
what we way outdid them in 18
and 19. and we picked up
if you have somebody smart you got to
have somebody smart
but if you have somebody smart in this
position you're president
they'll never overtake you they'll never
ever overview they have more people but
they'll never overtake you you have
somebody smart
biden's nafta and china deals wiped out
one third of your state's
manufacturing jobs you know that better
than anybody biden shouldn't be asking
for your vote he should be begging for
your forgiveness
a little hokey he'll help people in a
true sense this election is a choice
between
pennsylvania and china or whatever
state we're talking about in china but
we're doing well you know it's
interesting we signed a great deal the
farmers have done more business in the
last two three
weeks biggest corn orders ever the
biggest soybean biggest cattle biggest
beef waters but you know it doesn't mean
as much to me
the ink wasn't even dry and the plague
came over mike right
it wasn't even dry just doesn't mean
what it would have meant we made a great
deal but it doesn't mean the same
anymore
because they could have stopped it from
coming here if biden wins
china wins and where's hunter wins
where's hunter
i walks into china walks out with a
billion and a half dollars
to manage and the most sophisticated
guys in wall street
i know they're smart they can't do that
and it took them 10 minutes walked out
with a billion and a half dollars to
manage you make millions of dollars a
year on that
when we win pennsylvania wins and
america wins and that's what's happening
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding
foreign nations fighting foreign wars
in areas and countries that you've never
even heard of
and defending foreign borders but now
we're
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities
and we are bringing our jobs our
factories and our trips
back home to the usa where they belong
now our opponents are pledging to rejoin
the job-killing
paris climate accord a disaster for our
country
it was meant to hurt us it was meant
really to take advantage of us we would
have spent trillions of dollars you
would have ended up closing a lot of
your plants and factories
and i said i'm going to do this i'm
going to get out of this crazy deal and
i did i said oh they're going to kill me
you know what
the people got it they they understood
it it was
ripping off our country because we have
things that they don't have like
unbelievable wealth under our ground
they don't want to see you said oh
that's nice that's a wonderful thing
thank you very much
i withdrew from that catastrophe because
i was elected to fight for
pennsylvania not for paris
and we're putting a member it's been a
long time right
from day one i put america first to
defend our workers i impose
tariffs on foreign aluminum and foreign
steel
i saved the auto industry by withdrawing
from the horrible trans-pacific
partnership would have killed what i've
done for michigan
in particular also pennsylvania but what
i've done
for them with autos forget it they're
building 17 or expanding 17 different
plants
they hadn't built one in 42 years
and we're building a lot of them we have
countries you want to do business with
us go in and build auto plants
i ended the nafta nightmare and signed
the brand new u.s mexico canada
agreement into law which is great
and you're not going to be losing
companies
to mexico and canada very
disadvantageous for them to do that
i took the toughest ever action to stand
up to china's rampant theft
of pennsylvania's jobs i proudly signed
a historic
executive order making it official
government policy
to buy american and hire american
now i watched
biden two weeks ago what's going on
this lid you know what a lid is he keeps
putting bernie keeps putting a lid
he's got a lit it's eight o'clock in the
morning he's a now a lit means you're
out for the day that means the fake
news media can go home
you know he's got one they've got the
easiest job i've ever seen they never
have to work
the media please go home there won't be
any activity from sleepy joe biden today
he's a low-energy individual
now you know you need a president with a
lot of energy you deal with
president xi of china president putin of
russia
kim jong-un remember we're going to be
in a war with north korea right what
happened what
what happened to the war what happened
we didn't do anything same you know we
didn't do anything but
millions of people could have been
killed in that nuclear war probably
would have been nuclear but look at it
right
you know getting along with these
foreign nations not a bad thing
they say oh we get so long yeah i asked
obama i was saying he told me the
biggest problem we had was north korea
and he was telling me why he sell me
lots of horses i said uh
excuse me have you ever tried calling
him
and i got nominated for two nobel prizes
one is for israel
and bahrain and the united arab
emirates right and and by the way many
countries are coming and they're all
calling oh we want to come in they're
going to all come in no more blood in
the sand no we just did it smart we
we reversed it the heart of the deal
it's the art of common sense let me tell
you
we're reversed and uh many countries are
going to come in
and i told the story the other night
then i got one for kosovo and serbia
they've been killing each other for many
years just killing each other they don't
get along
they don't they're sort of like the
palestinians in israel sort of have to i
have kosovo and
and you know we're dealing with both of
them i said to them why are you
fighting and killing each other they
have a lot of differences including a
religious difference i guess
i said what are you doing and we trade
with both so we have certain power
so i said listen let's get a deal let's
make economic peace and ultimately peace
they came to my office the oval office
to sign they were hugging they were so
i mean it was a beautiful thing to see
we saved a lot of lives
and i told this last night i said to my
i said to my great first lady our great
first lady
melania i said melania first lady
i said first lady oh i'm gonna watch
television tonight i'm gonna come home
early
because let me tell you 6 30 is very
early i stay in there
late but i'm going to come home early
i'm going to show you what a great job i
just got
nominated for the nobel peace prize
and we're gonna sit there and i'm gonna
just soak it in darling let's turn on
nbc fake news
lester holt
number two rated show he's number two
heading south i find nbc to be worse
than
the other they spend all that money on
their pr and i screwed up in one evening
like this
because when obama got it nobody knew
what he got it for including him
remember they said what did you get it
for i don't know
that's how different we have to work
harder he got a
nobel prize and he didn't have any idea
why he got it
then he started dropping bombs two weeks
later in some place that didn't work out
couldn't work out because he had john
kerry negotiating who was the worst
incompetent now it's so sad that iran
that
horrible deal
that was a fast plane
that must have been one of the new ones
we just bought you know
we have all new equipment that was scary
if i'm the enemy i don't want to hear
that sound
but i said to our first lady first lady
turn on the television
turn it on darling it's going to be a
big evening
i toast you but i don't drink darling
just don't drink
not so bad so we turned it on and they
did a story in the weather
it was raining heavily in a certain area
and they did a story on something else
something else
and something else then they went into
another story then another then they had
a commercial that lasted for about nine
minutes
even though you know they're not
supposed to make money
they're using our free airways for fake
news okay they're using free airways
think about that we're thinking about
that we're thinking about that why are
they using
free airwaves to give fake news
so it came toward the end i said darling
i'm a little embarrassed but the
following day
i got nominated for another one i called
her up i said you know maybe they forgot
so let's go home and turn on the
television it was exciting
they had another story that this time
they're cleaning up the rain
another one another one another one got
to the commercial never ended
got back a little tiny piece and i said
they didn't cover two nobel prizes
i got two in one week did you ever hear
that one for different things totally
unrelated
and my only complaint is i should have
gotten about seven or eight because if
you knew some of the other
some of the other things i've done are
much better i should have gotten seven
but the fake news never even put it on
and somebody had a show where they said
the amount of time devoted to donald
trump's
nobel peace prize two of them zero on
the network
zero then the amount of time devoted to
something else that was
negative for somebody in the republican
party like
infinite it is so disgraceful
they're so bad but we just have to keep
on winning you know there's nothing like
winning just keep on winning
keep on winning
[Applause]
see now they'll tell that story
differently they won't tell it as you
know we do it in fun because i
understand them you have to laugh if you
can't laugh
you'd be out of here fast right like
beto when he said
i was born to run for president that was
yet
on a magazine he was on a fake magazine
vanity fair which is dying that suckers
died
those magazines are going down fast but
he was on a fake magazine vanity fair i
think
and he started saying about uh
you know he had a good week good week
and he started saying i was born
i was born to do this i was born to
run for president i said he's not going
to last very long
and about two weeks later it was over he
was put in charge of taking your guns
away though by biden you know that right
nato how do you get the name beto he
needed a little spanish because his last
name is bitter or o'rourke
where does the beto come from another
phony deal going on there
to protect american workers during the
pandemic
i suspended the entry of foreign workers
who threaten u.s jobs and we will always
care
for our citizens first
[Music]
biden's pledge to terminate these
protections
and give away your jobs under my
administration we've achieved
the most secure border in u.s history
and we are just finished that beautiful
wall that wall
340 miles 340
they don't talk about the law
build that wall build that wall
they don't talk about the wall i got
sued by
nancy pelosi craziness i got sued
and i made one big mistake in the wall
i'd always say we have to build the wall
builder we'll build the wall right
i should have just said very simply we
will not
build the wall the money would have come
pouring
they would have insisted that we build
it and remember walls work remember when
they said walls don't work
walls don't work they want to give us uh
drones
so we can watch the people pour across
the border
drones put a drone half a mile up in the
air you can watch everybody
come into the united states now remember
that though they said well but two
things work and i say it all the time
you know when you come up when you're a
brilliant scientist you develop a new
chip you develop a new
laptop
get beat up by the media they're
incredible you would have think of the
hundreds of thousands of people they
take out of here real bad ones to
murderers killers drug dealers
by contrast joe biden supports open
borders
zero deportations that's in the
manifesto
and sanctuary cities that release
violent criminal aliens that's what they
are they protect the criminal not
our people if you want to end sanctuary
cities
you have only one choice and that's vote
republican you know how bad it
is you know all of these places that
you're reading about all of them
they're all democrat-run cities and
states all of them they're all democrat
run
because they have no law and order all
they have to do is call us and say we'll
be in but they have no law and order
they have nothing they're all democrat
run they're a disaster
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military and launched
the first new branch of the u.s armed
forces in nearly 75 years
the space force
[Applause]
and that's going to be very important i
did more in 47 months
than sleepy joe biden did in 47 years
that's true that's really good
we killed the founder and leader of isis
al baghdadi
we took out the world's number one
terrorist and the mass murder of
american troops and others
salamani
[Applause]
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal they paid 150
billion dollars for nothing they got
nothing
you know i don't mind the 150 what i
mind they gave 1.8 billion in cash what
is one point that would
fill up this whole area right 1.8 plane
loads of cash
that's when i realized that a president
is very powerful when you can do that
send that money to a foreign country and
no friend
it's crazy i kept my promise
recognize the true capital of israel
and open the american embassy in
jerusalem
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know who likes that the most the
evangelicals like it the most you know
that
the evangelicals love it we're just with
franklin graham and a lot of great
people
they had a very successful event at the
mall today i don't know if you heard
about it was great
franklin graham all of the top
evangelical and other leaders they were
great
they were at the white house ceremony
today for the justice
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
and instead of the endless wars we are
forging peace
all over the middle east and it's
costing nothing
costing them not killing people no blood
in the sand
you know they're tired of fighting by
the way just in case even these
people that like to fight they're tired
19 years in afghanistan they're tired
they all want to sort of relax
as tough as they may be joe biden
opposed the mission to take out osama
bin laden
he opposed killing salamani he voted for
the iraq war he backed
the disastrous iran nuclear deal a total
horror show
and he cheered the rise of china as a
very positive development for the united
states okay
not so positive now biden is pushing the
most far-left
platform in the history of our country
the biden plan would destroy social
security and destroy protections
for pre-existing conditions you know
that they want to go socialize medicine
socialize medicine go to a hospital and
take care of yourself get rid of 180
million
private plans that people love he would
terminate our travel bans on jihadist
regions we won the travel ban remember
and increase refugee admission 700
percent
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism
he wants to ban school choice and ban
charter schools terrible
in a second term i will provide school
choice to
every parent in america
[Applause]
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great
jobs and a limitless future for all
americans and in conclusion
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
that time
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
second amendment we will strike down
terrorists to threaten our citizens and
we will
keep america out of these endless
ridiculous
stupid foreign wars in countries that
you've never even heard of
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military
might and we will ensure peace through
strength you know we rebuilt our
military you saw 2.5 trillion dollars
we have weapons the
[Music]
i mean just to talk about them the likes
of which
no country has ever seen before the
power the strength the
the uh incredible talent and engineering
we have weapons the likes of which no
country
has ever seen before we are so far
advanced over every other country
and hope to god we never have to use
them and when i got here we were a
depleted
tired military with great people but we
were exhausted we had old jet fighters
now we have brand new f-35s that are
stealth
i asked one of the pilots how good are
these planes compared to the enemy you
say well one difference is you can't see
our planes
i said let me ask you i don't know too
much about flying that helps doesn't he
said it really helps
the guy looked like tom cruise but
better
tom cruise but stronger
we will end surprise medical billing
require price transparency
and further reduce health insurance
premiums and the cost of prescription
drugs
we will strongly protect medicare and
social security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars very soon
and nasa has become the preeminent
space center again in the world it was
tired it was over we will stop
the radical indoctrination of our
students and restore patriotic
education to our school
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the people of pennsylvania
so get your friends get your family
get your neighbors get your co-workers
and get out and vote most important
election we've ever had the most
important we've ever had early voting
has already begun
so don't wait go out and vote from erie
to easton
from pittsburgh to harrisburg and from
allentown to right here in
middletown we stand on the shoulders of
pennsylvania patriots who gave their
blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
this is an incredible place our whole
history so much history in pennsylvania
this is the state where our founding
fathers declared
american independence it's where the
army weathered its brutal winter at
valley forge
where general george washington led his
men on a daring mission across the
delaware
and where our union was saved by the
heroes of gettysburg
this is the place where generations of
tough
pennsylvania workers mined the call
worked the railroads and forged the
steel that made america
into the greatest and most powerful
nation in the history of the world
and you haven't seen anything yet
[Music]
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning
power to you the american people with
your help
your devotion we're going to keep on
working
we're going to keep on fighting and
we're going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together with the incredible people of
pennsylvania
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again and we
will make america great again
thank you very much thank you
pennsylvania go out and vote
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
young man there's no need to feel down i
said a young man
[Music]
young man when you're short on your
dough
you can stay there and i'm sure you will
find
many ways to have a
good time
it's fun to
[Applause]
[Music]
you can get to something and you can
have a good meal
you can do whatever
[Applause]
but you've got to know this
what a thing no man does it all by
himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
you can hang out with all the boys
[Music]
i was once
[Music]
someone came up to me and said come in
take a walk up the street it's a place
there
called the ymca they can't stop
your way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
young man